[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute eine
Regenbogen criptorte generell finde ich
Crêpes Torten sehr sehr lecker einfach
wenn man diesen dünnen feinen kreppteig
geschichtet mit einer leckeren Creme hat
und ich dachte mir warum ich gleich
Regenbogenfarben sieht einfach cooler
aus und vielleicht habt den Anlass das
Dach zu backen bzw eigentlich ist es ja
gar nicht richtig Backen man backt ihr
nur die Crêpes aus und der Rest geht
zucki ich schreibe euch wie immer alle
ganz genauen Mengenangaben hier unten in
die Infobox und ich gebe jetzt
zuallererst mein Mehl hier in meine
Schüssel ihr braucht doch keine Maschine
das mache ich einfach jetzt mit dem
Schneebesen und da kommt jetzt Milch
hinzu und dann wird es Klümpchen frei
verrührt mit dem Schneebesen
[Musik]
so die Eier habe ich vorab miteinander
verquält dann lösen sie sich einfach
besser auf in der Masse einfach mit
dazugeben natürlich fehlt dann noch
Zucker und Vanilleextrakt für den
Geschmack das darf er mir nie fehlen
habe ich auch direkt mit dazu ich muss
sagen das ist echt ein richtig richtig
schneller Teig da braucht man sich gar
nicht so kompliziert machen
dazu und für den Geschmack weil es
einfach Geschmacksträger ist und
leckerer schmeckt Butter die habe ich
vorab in der Mikrowelle zerlassen
einfach bei geringer Wattzahl und dann
ganz zum Schluss noch mit dazu geben
also wir brauchen da jetzt sechs Tage
weil wir sechs Farben haben ihr könnt
natürlich auch eine andere Farbe Kombi
nehmen und dann nur vier Farben oder
drei aber ich finde sechs müssen schon
sein so und dafür brauche ich jetzt
einfach meine Küchenwaage ich gebe jetzt
hier ich hätte natürlich auch vorher den
Schlüssel einmal abwiegen können um mir
die Zahlen notieren können ich habe
zufällig noch eine zweite setzt die
Waage auf 0 und wenn ich jetzt die
Schüssel hier drauflege sehe ich wie
viel Teig ich habe das sind bei mir
1680 g es kann auch bei euch ein
bisschen weniger sein weil die Eier ja
ein anderes Volumen haben und dann habe
ich hier gerechnet 1680 geteilt durch 6
Farben sind 280g Teig die Farbe das
werde ich mir jetzt hier einmal
aufteilen und dann einfach alles schön
einfärben
[Musik]
so ich habe alle Teige jetzt schön
eingefärbt also noch sind die Töne passt
ehrlich ich wollte sie extra nicht so
knallig aber wir können natürlich auch
mehr Farbe rein geben damit knalliger
wird möchte gerne so ein pastelligen
Regenbogen haben jetzt habe ich hier 22
cm Pfannen ihr könnt das natürlich auch
alles in einer Pfanne machen das ist
kein Problem ich habe zufällig zweiter
deswegen nutze ich das um ein bisschen
Zeit zu sparen jetzt könnt ihr so ein
bisschen backtrennspray immer wieder
dazugeben und dann da habe ich jetzt
einfach als Maßstab meinen
Eisportionierer oder auch Teig
Portionierer und da gebe ich dann immer
eine Kelle von rein und backt sie kurz
von beiden Seiten aus
und so mache ich das jetzt mit allen
Farben
[Musik]
so die Crepes sind fertig ich finde sie
optisch extrem schön die kommen jetzt
noch ganz kurz an die Seite und dadurch
dass das so ein bisschen Zeit intensiver
war wird unsere Creme um so einfacher
ich nehme jetzt hier die Küchenmaschine
ihr könntet auch euer Handrührgerät
verwenden das dauert immer ein bisschen
länger so und was bei mir immer mitkommt
wenn ich bei Kaufland einkaufen gehe so
die Klassiker Mascarpone und Sahne weil
man kann da immer ganz gut mit dem
Geschmack spielen ich gebe da nämlich
gleich Vanilleextrakt dazu dann hat man
einfach so eine leckere Vanillecreme und
wenn die Zutaten alle schön kalt sind
und ihr sie ganz frisch aus dem
Kühlschrank nehmen könnt ihr alles auf
einmal aufschlagen und dann wird auch
die Mascarpone nicht flüssig und rührt
ihr einfach so lange bis die Masse schön
steif bzw dick cremig ist so die zwei
Sahnebecher noch mit rein dann für die
süße natürlich etwas Puderzucker den
braucht ihr nicht sieben einfach direkt
dazugeben es sei denn ihr habt euch
Lagerung dicke Klümpchen dann könnte das
gerne einmal durchziehen so
Vanilleextrakt und dann rühre ich
erstmal langsam werde dann immer
schneller mit der Geschwindigkeit und
gibt dann währenddessen Sahnefest dazu
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt endlich der spaßige Teil
freue ich mich schon die ganze Zeit
drauf wir Schichten jetzt die Crêpes mit
unserer Creme und dann nehme ich mir
direkt schon eine schöne Tortenplatte
worauf ich das erwähnen kann und da die
haben mit der Reihenfolge könnte das
einfach selbst entscheiden so ich
platziere das jetzt hier und da gibt's
eigentlich echt nicht viel zu sagen weil
eigentlich habe ich mir wirklich nur
eine Winkelpalette verstreichen ein
bisschen Creme und dann kommt das
nächste Crêpes drauf ach was ich euch
sagen wollte haben sie scheinbar doch so
schön ausgebacken dass doch sechs krebsi
Farbe rausbekommen sind hätte sie
vielleicht ein bisschen minimal dicker
gemacht hätte ich auch nur fünf
rausbekommen aber das ist ja persönliche
Präferenz ne also ob wir da jetzt fünf
oder sechs raus bekommt der tut sich
glaube ich nichts
[Musik]
also ich muss sagen als ich die Torte
angeschnitten habe Game Over das war das
sieht so schön aus Entschuldigung
ja genau ja
so besser die sich beschreiben können
also ich finde die auch so von dem
Pastelltönen her echt schön aber vom
Geschmack ist ja alle gleich essen das
war einfach nur Lebensmittelfarbe die
sollte jetzt vanillig schmecken also man
kommt auch ganz gut durch mit der Gabel
also ich habe Vanille im Teig und
Vanillecreme man kommt echt gut durch
mit der Gabel braucht kein Messer oder
so Crepes sind e-weiß und durch die
Feuchtigkeit
genau aber ist gar nicht so sich mit
sehr frisch sehr oft also sehr angenehm
man kommt einfach so mit der Gabel durch
die Schichten
ja aber andersrum also so so
sehr lecker und echt frisch muss ich
sagen das ist nicht so eine leichte
Torte aber sie liegt auch nicht so krass
ja muss ich auch sagen es ist schon also
die Hälfte deswegen kann man das auch so
machen ne dass man die anschneidet und
auf dem Teller in der Hälfte nochmal
Durchschnitt aber das schöne ist ja
alles klar
egal ob Mann Frau Kind Onkel Tante Opa
habe ich nämlich auch gedacht
oder keine Ahnung alles mögliche sehr
schön alles mögliche also der anstatt
das ist einfach das ist jetzt
nein das ist richtig das ist ein perfekt
sein müssen so ich wünsche euch jetzt
viel Spaß beim Nachmachen falls ihr
Fragen habt schreibt sie auf jeden Fall
unten in die Kommentare damit ich immer
aktiv und ansonsten sehen wir uns zum
nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]